ja danke marx dankte julian nämlich mit
dieser karte hier diese karte müssen
auch sie kennen heute es ist die
spritpreise entwicklung bevor wir dazu
im detail kommen die aktuellste meldung
dass die us regierung gerade angekündigt
hat alle öl- und gaslieferungen aus
russland zu stoppen die bundesregierung
macht das noch nicht und trotzdem sehen
wir an der zapfsäule schon eine massive
preisentwicklung jeder der heute tanken
war hat es gespürt zum ersten mal der
preis im schnitt in deutschland für e10
und für diesel deutlich über 2 euro
aktuell liegen wir hier gerade
aktualisiert diese kurve zwei euro 15
und 2 euro 11 für diesel also einmal das
e10 und einmal diesel 2 eur 11 und jetzt
gucken wir auf die karte der billigsten
und teuersten tankstellen die gleichen
sich im stundenrhythmus an vor heute
vormittag hatten wir teilweise noch
preise deutlich unter 2 euro aber das
ist jetzt geschichte in deutschland wir
sehen hier aktuell in flensburg das ist
die teuerste tankstelle aktuell 2 eur 19
für diese ganz unten im süden gibt es
das den liter diesel noch für zwei euro
9 aber das wie gesagt alles preise die
unvorstellbar war noch vor drei vier
monaten super in kaiserslautern noch
vergleichsweise günstig mit zwei euro 8
und in bremen aktuell bei 2 euro 16 also
das direkte auswirkungen des ukraine
krieges bei uns hier an den tanksäulen
wir schauen noch einmal auf diese karte
die uns den ländervergleich zeigt sie
wissen in deutschland der steueranteil
ganz besonders hoch auf benzin und
diesel wir sind aktuell wie gesagt bei
diesen preisen deutlich jenseits der
zwei euro grenze und dann schauen wir
mal rüber nach polen dort aktuell nach
einer steuersenkung super bei 1 euro 22
und diesel bei 1 euro 23 also fast ein
euro günstiger aktuell der liter benzin
nicht ganz so aber immer noch deutlich
günstiger in tschechien und eben auch
bei unseren nachbarn in österreich
darüber wollen wir sprechen jetzt mit
zwei tank warten die uns zugeschaltet
sind hier live bei bild live nämlich mit
favorit aus emmendingen den baden
württemberg in der nähe von freiburg und
einige aus delligsen in niedersachsen
schönen guten tag bei bild live
zeigen sie uns einmal ganz kurz wenn sie
raus gucken auf ihre tankstelle wo
liegen sie im moment beim liter super
beim liter e10 beim liter diesel
ich möchte mich jetzt um drill zum
google stehe ich nicht
haben halt auch weit über 2 euro weit
über 2 euro buy-in der manager ist das
vermutlich auch spätestens im laufe
dieses tages passiert
ja hier gab es gar kein störgeräusch ihr
habt jetzt nicht gehört aber ich habe
mich so hingestellt das zu dem fest mit
dem hintergrund vielleicht sehen können
als wir liegen auch genau zwischen den
beiden genannt haben es ist natürlich
erschreckend so was ist bei uns sie auch
tatsächlich bekomme ich kann mir so was
so kann man so eine situation nicht
erinnern dass wir so starke sprünge in
so kurzer zeit gesehen enrique was sagen
ihnen die kunden was sagen ihnen die
autofahrer die heute bei ihnen tanken
waren sind die wütende oder zeigen die
vor allem verständnis das ist ja was was
wir jetzt auch seit einigen tagen
natürlich wissen das genau das passieren
wird
ja wieso immer gibt es gegen kunden
natürlich nicht die wut ist natürlich
großen auch das entsetzen über über die
jetzt vorliegende preise aber man kann
im allgemeinen sagen dass die kunden
noch mit unseren mitarbeitern und uns
aktiv sind weil wir ja alle wissen wir
sehen bilder aus der ukraine wir haben
und seit ihrer clique gehört und dagegen
sind unsere finanziellen probleme
natürlich noch luxusprobleme die wut ist
groß aber vor allen dingen auf russland
vor allen dingen auch putin kann man
sagen das ist klar der effekt des
ukraine kriegs für den hat man natürlich
verständnis da fühlt man sich ganz klein
wenn man hier über preise spricht und
trotzdem verriet wir wissen ja wie hoch
der steueranteil ist also wie groß ist
der druck von ihren kunden auf die
politik bei uns dass sie an der
steuerschraube gedreht
ja ich glaube dass viele kunden gar
nicht wissen wie hoch der steuersatz ist
dass der fast die hälfte beträgt zb
kleinen die mehrwertsteuer ich höre über
uns mit 119 prozent also fast 20 prozent
noch einmal wahnsinnig hoch und höher
als heute sagt
das erste tier das die märkte
runterkommt es wurde jetzt gerade
österreich angesprochen die haben viel
weniger steuer und abgabe auf benzin und
diesel wie wir in deutschland
so ist es herr männicke letzte frage
womit rechnen sie für die nächsten tage
sie haben ja schon können so ein
bisschen in die zukunft gucken
vielleicht was den benzinpreis bei ihnen
betrifft also wie wird es weitergehen in
den nächsten tagen
ja normalerweise können wir natürlich
nicht in die zukunft gucken weil wir uns
jeden tag unsere preise holen und dann
auf nach deckung kalkulieren das heißt
wir gucken was sie bezahlen müssen für
die menge die wir heute verkaufen wenn
wir die hand china voll machen wollen
was wir momentan erleben hatten wir so
auf die preise über das wochenende sind
so stark gestiegen dass das bis jetzt
nicht schaffen konnten die gesamten
preise überhaupt wenn dem verbraucher
weiterzugeben wenn ich also meine
einkaufspreise gestern und vorgestern
sehr für die jetzt meine chance wieder
voll machen muss dann stand er da nichts
gutes also wenn wir uns keine technische
gegenreaktion relativ schnell sehen und
nach den aktuellen diskussionen scheint
das ja ausgeschlossen zu sein dann wird
sich der trend eher noch fortsetzen und
wir werden weiter deutlich steigende
preise zumindest für die nächsten tage
zu erwarten keine guten aussichten bei
der preisentwicklung danke ihnen dank
herr männicke dank harry zwei tankwarte
zu den aktuellen explodierenden
spritpreisen hierbei bild live schauen
wir noch mal kurz darauf habe die karte
hier also wir sind bei deutlich über 2
euro bei 215 für den liter benzin und
bei 211 für den liter diesel und
erinnern uns dabei an die spritpreis
bremse andreas scheuer hatte jedoch
angekündigt auf der zielgeraden als
verkehrsminister da hat er hier bei bild
live gesagt wenn das ding hier über zwei
euro ist da muss die politik eingreifen
schauen sie doch mal rein
ich denke bei zwei euro muss die politik
einschalten ganz genau so war es und
heute hat er dann bei twitter noch mal
nachgelegt hat sich selber nämlich
erinnert an diesen satz hierbei bild
live und hat gesagt ja was passiert
jetzt gut er selbst ist nicht mehr
zuständig sein nachfolger volker wissing
dem kippte das jetzt sozusagen vor die
füße und vor allen dingen dem
finanzminister christian lindner gibt er
das vor die füße und der hat sich in den
tagen auch geäußert hier am sonntag ganz
genau am sonntagabend christian lindner
und sagt dass zu steuersenkungen auf
sprit
also es gibt keinerlei überlegungen
derzeit die steuern auf sprit zu senken
ein
ganz klares nein darüber müssen wir
sprechen hier im studium mit bildpolitik
chef jan schäfer schönen guten tag
jahren und ganz klares nein um an der
steuerschraube zu drehen wie lange hält
er das durch der finanzminister ich
glaube das wird schwierig für christian
lindner wir sehen einen dramatischen
anstieg du hast es gerade auch
beschrieben erstmals im bundesschnitt
heute
benzinpreise benzin und diesel also
super und diesel von dem durchschnitt
zwei euro unter drüber das ist extrem
viel wenn wir einmal schauen wie viele
liter benzin dieselkraftstoff und auch
super pro tag verkauft werden in
deutschland sind im schnitt rund 180
millionen und wenn es da die steuerung
gibt um beispielsweise 50 cent das ist
noch gar nicht lange her dass der liter
dose 150 160 gekostet hat dann sind wir
schon bei 90 millionen euro mehr
was die bundesbürger am tag zahlen
müssen für den liter sprit das ist im
monat sind das 2,7 milliarden das ist
nicht lange durchzuhalten und die frage
ist nur passiert das mit einer
entlastung noch vor der landtagswahl in
nordrhein westfalen im mai oder
möglicherweise erst danach einer der
demnächst wahlen hat im saarland nämlich
der macht auch zusätzlich druck auf die
bundesregierung das des saarlands
ministerpräsident obs hans der heute das
bei twitter gepostet hat schauen sie mal
morgen ich bin jetzt hier gerade an der
tankstelle vorbei gefahren
[Musik]
zwei euro 12 ich finde da ist jetzt
wirklich ein punkt erreicht wo man sagen
muss da muss man
klar hat das was mit der reine diese zu
tun und klar hat das was du dir die
bundesregierung mit beeinflussen kann
aber das problem ist doch einfach dass
im moment der stadt bereichert der stadt
bereichert sich an diesen gestiegenen
energiekosten und deswegen muss eine
preisblase her das trifft jetzt wird nur
geringverdiener sondern das trifft
wirklich die viele fleißige leute die
tanken müssen die ihre diesel-fahrzeuge
tanken die zur arbeit fahren die die
kinder zum sport bringen deswegen habe
ich die herzliche bitte unterstützt mich
dabei jetzt wirklich die stimme laut zu
machen gegenüber der bundesregierung des
brit weiß bleiben sie die muss jetzt her
zwei euro zwölf neuen film diesel soll
das geht wirklich nicht mehr ganz ja das
trifft nicht nur die geringverdiener das
trifft vor allen dingen die fleißigen
leute sagt tobias ans saarlands
ministerpräsident ich glaube da ist ihm
die formulierung bisschen verrutscht
darüber werden wir nachher aussprechen
mit ihnen werden ihnen gleich hier haben
bei bild live aber er wollte vor allen
dingen jan für diese spritpreis bremse
jetzt werden machte ordentlich druck wie
druck ist sehr groß ist der druck aus
reihen der opposition und auch vor der
ministerpräsidenten ja ich habe druck
ist insgesamt groß der druck ist aber
nicht nur groß war jetzt landtagswahlen
beispielsweise auch in zweieinhalb
wochen in saarland anstehen sondern eine
ist mit blick auf die anzeigentafel in
an den tankstellen einfach extrem groß
zwei euro das gab es bisher noch nicht
und du hast ja auch gerade beispiel
genannt von tankstellen der situation
bei zwei euro 20 zum teil schon auch
darüber dass das ist eigentlich für
viele menschen nicht mehr bezahlbar
andreas scheuer mit dem wir gestern
sprachen hat das auch gesagt und wenn
wir über das thema benzinpreis bremse
sprechen dann ist immer die frage am
ende auch was kann der staat was kann
die bundesregierung eigentlich tun ich
bin kein fan von rechte tasche linke
tasche nach dem motto ich knüpfe den
bürgern erst ganz viele steuern ab um
ihnen danach an anderer stelle wieder
geld zurückzugeben aber die frage die
man hier stellen kann es beispielsweise
brauchen wir einen so dramatischen
steueranteil eigentlich auf den
benzinpreis wir haben einen irren blog
nennt sich mittlerweile energie steuer
war früher die mineralölsteuer wir haben
eine co2 preisen auf den benzinpreis und
wir haben beispielsweise noch die
mehrwertsteuer obendrauf und die frage
ist muss da nicht ab geschichtet werden
also muss man bei der die steuer nicht
sagen wir müssen zu einer entlastung
kommen und müssten die beispielsweise um
10 20 cent senken denn was wir hier
sehen sind natürlich folgekosten des
krieges die angst vor noch weiter
steigenden preisen die führt ja eben
auch dazu dass die bundesregierung
bisher nicht stoppt macht mit russischem
öl russischen gas vor allen dingen daran
festhält jetzt kommt die meldung gerade
rein in dieser stunde von der us
regierung die genau das macht ihn klaren
schnitt macht und nein sagt zu putins öl
jetzt wächst auch da nochmal der druck
auf die bundesregierung dass diese woche
auch zu tun auf jeden fall die
amerikaner preschen dort vor es gibt
diese stimmen ja auch nicht nur aus
ukrainischer seite auch von deutscher
seite norbert röttgen beispielsweise cdu
außenpolitiker der ganz klar sagte wir
müssen die verbindungen die gasimporte
und die ölimporte aus russland sofort
stoppen denn putin finanziert natürlich
mit dem geld was er jetzt von uns
bekommt seinen krieg und je höher die öl
und gaspreise steigen umso mehr geld
fließt ja ironischerweise in die kassen
von putin umso länger hält er den krieg
auch durch jetzt muss man einst bedenken
die amerikaner haben es deutlich
einfacher weil sie diese worte genau aus
russland zu stoppen beziehen ungefähr
sieben prozent ihres öls aus russland in
deutschland ist es ein drittel also wir
sind damit deutlich höher und die
kernfrage wird sein wo bekommen wir denn
das öl dann her aber ich glaube wenn wir
über die frage kosten sprechen der krieg
den putin gegen die ukraine führt wird
teuer für den westen so oder so ob wir
mit waffen liefern lieferung dabei sind
ob dies möglicherweise angreift und wir
direkt in einen krieg gezogen werden
oder ob wir sagen wir müssen die
lieferung aus russland stoppen und
zahlen dafür einen höheren preis bei
unserer energie ein drittel des
deutschen öls von putin ungefähr die
hälfte unseres gases von putin in den
vergangenen jahren wurde darüber gelacht
in deutschland wir schauen uns noch mal
eine szene an von den vereinten nationen
das ist drei jahre alt das video das
geht gerade wieder viral dort damals
eine rede bei den vereinten nationen von
dem damaligen us präsidenten donald
trump wir erinnern uns und er spricht
dort wir können es gerade mal zeigen vor
den vereinten nationen und die deutsche
delegation damals mit außenminister
heiko maas lacht sich die worte kaputt
das ist das damalige video von bild
damals nicht so wahnsinnig beachtet aber
in diesen tagen eben drei millionen mal
aufgerufen
die rede von dem er sagt deutschland
wird vollkommen abhängig von russischer
energie werden wenn es nicht sofort
seinen kurs ändert und dann sitzen
hinten drin heiko maas und der damalige
merkel berater christoph heusgen und sie
schütteln nur den kopf und lachen über
diese aussage chance ja ja das ist eine
historische fehleinschätzung und ich
weiß gar nicht ob die herrschaften dort
über trump gelacht haben oder über ihre
eigene kurze weil sie wussten dass
deutschland extrem abhängig ist von
russischem gas zu dem zeitpunkt mehr als
die hälfte und das war ja die zeit als
es um nord stream zwei große debatten
gaben und die frage bekommen wir also
noch mehr russisches gas und wenn wir
noch mehr russisches gas bezogen hätten
wäre unsere abhängigkeit natürlich noch
größer geworden also anschauen die kann
man darüber lachen das ist bis heute ein
großes rätsel wir können ja mal schauen
was heiko maas damals beispielsweise
gesagt hat in diesen tagen damals haben
ihnen natürlich journalisten begleitet
auf seiner reise und dort wurde dann
dieses zitat wiedergegeben es gibt keine
abhängigkeit deutschlands von russland
sagte damals heiko maas der damalige
außenminister schon gar nicht in der
energiefragen wir werden auch nicht müde
werden die echten fakten dem
entgegenzusetzen das war damals die tat
formen bundesaußenminister und auch im
jahr
2019 damals die meldung über angela
merkel die ganz klar das sagte wir
können das noch mal zeigen eine
agenturmeldung damals von reuters merkel
weist die sorge vor russischer gas
abhängigkeit zurück da kann man nur
sagen in welcher welt haben sowohl
angela merkel als auch heiko maas in
dieser zeit gelebt wird hat er immer
ganz klar darauf hingewiesen dass es
eine extreme abhängigkeit gibt und wir
sehen ja heute auch wie falsch angela
merkel und wie falsch heiko maas auch
lagen denn wir sehen wie schwer ist die
aktuelle bundesregierung hat bestehen
aus spd der partei von heiko maas grünen
und fdp jetzt für möglichen ersatz zum
russischen gas zu sorgen also sollten
wir die importe komplett auf null
stellen ist die große frage wir kommen
durch den frühling und den sommer noch
durch die gasspeicher sind noch
einigermaßen gefüllt aber wo kommt denn
dann das gas her was wir dringend
brauchen und wir sehen ja mit welchem
hochdruck in der bundesregierung gerade
gearbeitet wir zu gucken die körper das
ausgleichen also extreme abhängigkeit
von russischem gas das was heiko maas
angela merkel gesagt habe ist einfach
falsch war einfach weg news und die
bundesregierung sitzt in einem
gewaltigen dilemma auf der einen seite
zieht die
preis schraube immer weiter an und auf
der anderen seite macht eben die us
regierung beispielsweise jetzt auch
tatsachen indem sie sagt nein zu allen
russischen öllieferungen vielen dank
politik chef jan schäfer hier im studio
ja das ist eine meldung dieses tages
dass die usa ab sofort alle öl importe
aus russland stoppt nein so putin dazu
sprechen wir jetzt mit herbert
bauernebel unserem us korrespondenten in
new york das kommt einigermaßen
überraschend im moment diese meldung und
setzt die bundesregierung weiter unter
druck wie kann das in den vergangenen
stunden zustande möglicherweise auch
dort zunehmender druck auf den us
präsidenten herbert ja das tempo ist
atemberaubend keine frage der es wird
zwar diskutiert in den letzten tagen
wurde diskutiert ebendiese diesen
schritt zu setzen der druck kam die
sonders seitens des kongresses auch aus
joe biden eigener partei den demokraten
nancy pelosi hat sich diesbezüglich
bereits in der vorwoche geäußert die
speakerin des repräsentantenhauses es
gibt auch überparteiliche maßnahmen
einer initiative die hier im kongress
verhandelt wurden in den letzten tagen
und beschlossen wurden oder zumindest
vorgelegt worden die in diese richtung
gehen und jetzt schon beiden geht
offensichtlich in die offensive kam was
das tempo betrifft doch ein wenig
überraschend aber es ist ein klarer
schritt ein klares signal an russland
wie gesagt natürlich amerika kann sich
dass mehr leisten als europa ausland
exportiert ungefähr 100.000 barrel pro
tag an die usa oder exportierte noch vor
wenigen wochen das sind ungefähr fünf
prozent der russischen
energieexporte die nach amerika gehen
aber trotzdem natürlich der schritt
drückt auf den ölpreis des faspo war
gestern bei der 130 dollar wird weiter
nach oben schießen so wie ein rohstoff
händler vermuten das hat natürlich
auswirkungen auf die ganze
weltwirtschaft und natürlich auch hier
in den usa auf die autofahrer gerade
wurde bekannt gegeben dass die
amerikaner die höchsten spritpreise in
ihrer gesamten geschichte gerade
bezahlen ja aber die sind weit weg weit
entfernt von unseren spritpreisen hier
in deutschland danke herbert bauernebel
nach new york an den times square danke